i need to open by stating the fact that
this video is not my original artistic
vision
however you can see that by signing up
to my patreon and getting the director's
cut
[Music]
does artistic freedom
include the ability to change
a piece of art
this is a much more philosophical
concept to generally talk about although
i'm going to bring it down to
straight logistics uh as much as i'm
able to
when i say an artist changing their own
work
what am i talking about because
obviously artists they
change that's the entire artistic
creative process you don't just
submit your first draft unless you're el
james
so what am i even talking about when i
talk about an
artist changing their art well first
thing is let's put a timestamp on it
i'm talking about the alteration of a
piece of art
after it has been made available to the
public
anything done to the artwork prior to
that point
that's kind of a different conversation
and there are conversations to be had
about the environment in which an artist
is allowed to work and how much freedom
they have within that environment
but that's not a conversation i'm really
up for having although i'll touch on
certain elements
at one point i mainly want to focus on
what do we do
about an artist who wants to change a
piece of art after
it is already out there now
given the fact that i have repeatedly
espoused the idea of death of the author
it shouldn't be too surprising to
anybody that broadly speaking and most
of the time i'm gonna say
no no you shouldn't be able to do that
because you are
affecting the available experience and
also potentially trying to remove the
experience
that some of your audience or viewers or
consumers of your art have had
you are taking that experience away from
them and replacing it with something
else
and while you maybe can say well they
have their memories of the original
version memories are
fallible your memory of the experience
is not the original experience
memory is not only valuable it is
malleable
so if they come in and experience your
new version
that might ultimately just supersede
their memory of the original version so
you
are taking something away when you
update a piece of art after it's already
been out there
obviously the quintessential version of
this is
the star wars films the original trilogy
and
how many freaking times
george lucas altered those films
and every time he did
the versions he made prior to that would
not be released again
here's the funny thing about that though
while i feel to a certain degree
robbed of my original viewing experience
of those movies
my original viewing experience wasn't
actually pure in the first place
because the version of say a new hope
that i saw didn't have the original text
crawl
because the original text crawl when
first released to theaters didn't
say star wars episode 4 a new hope
it was later that that was added so that
was on the version that i saw that was
really the only major addition to the
version that i saw
but then later updates went on
and so here i am getting snippy about no
longer getting able to see the version
that i grew up with
when in truth the version i grew up with
isn't even
truly the original version but that adds
in an
extra layer when you're talking about a
piece of art that actually has
legs and sticks around generations
on because if you keep altering the
thing
then each new generation when they come
in whatever version is current is
their version and then if you update it
and change it again
you're now robbing multiple generations
of their version
yet at the same time only the original
generation of viewers truly knows the
original experience and everyone else is
already dealing with a modified version
see this is what i mean when i say that
things get
weird and murky trying to talk about
this
now let's also cop to the fact that
most artists if given the chance
would probably want to alter their
pieces of art
i don't know who first said it but there
is a saying that
90 of creators loathe everything they
made more than five years ago
and i don't know how absolutely
factually statistically accurate that is
but it certainly feels
accurate and as a creator
yeah i look at a lot of my old stuff
or i look at some of my old writings
and i think oh my god
what and i would want
those things altered i would want those
things changed i look
at the videos that were the start of
this channel which were scripted
shorts shot by me on a crappy camera
barely understanding angles not knowing
how to do lighting with a
freaking dang and i barely know how to
do it now but i could do it better now
than i did
then and i would happily
replace those with a new version
but should i be able to
i think part of the question if we're
getting more real world and practical
about it
is whether or not a revised version of a
piece of work
completely replaces the original piece
of
art or is it in addition to it
so there are now multiple versions
that would seem like the ideal
compromise wouldn't it
because if you have just to use the film
example because this sort of thing does
actually happen
with film not so much with something
like
paintings or a novel or what have you
but with something like film you you
will
not uncommonly have a theatrical release
and then a director's cut and if we have
both
isn't everything fine then
well from a consumer's perspective
possibly if we set aside the fact that
if they want to
uh get a full understanding experience
of the different alternate versions they
may have to pay to see the thing more
than once but let's
set that issue aside for the moment from
the consumer's
perspective yeah that seems to sort it
but from the artist perspective they're
now still compromised because
the version that they wish to replace is
still out there and this is where i'm
going to bring in a little bit of what i
set aside before
which is talking about the conditions
under which it was made in the first
place
now director's cuts for films are an odd
thing
for me because
there are and i think film possibly more
than any other medium medium aside from
video games where
you know changes to the original
artistic thing
could actually just be bug fixes so
that's even murkier
but outside of video games i'd say that
director's cuts and film you know is
something where it's been normalized for
us
but there's only been i to
my understanding in my opinion a
handful like less than half a dozen
instances of times when
an artistic vision was truly
killed when taken away from the director
and a director's cut proved that
their version was completely superior
and i'm not talking about little tweaks
i'm not talking about an extra 10
minutes i'm talking about
fundamentally it was a different movie
and in these cases a better one
there aren't a lot of examples where
that's actually happened
there's brazil there's blade runner
although even that one multiple versions
of the director's cut
and i would say kingdom of heaven
so i say there's probably about half a
dozen off the top my head i can only
name three
two of which are directed by ridley
scott go figure
but for as much as the director's cut
has become a staple
of the home viewing experience and the
release to home media
is that actually justified does it make
any sense
i mean obviously it's done
because they can make more money off it
but again let's set the capitalist
issue to the side
what is the artistic value
of two only marginally different
versions of a film and
this is gonna be an anecdotal thing but
i have noticed that
if over time only one
version kind of keeps going forward and
another one gets
more or less dropped it's usually the
theatrical cut that gets dropped
a movie that i quite enjoyed was
michael mann's the last of the mohicans
now i've got personal connection to this
because i'm actually named after the
lead character not from the movie from
the book i'm older than the movie
but i like that movie a lot
i think it's really good i think
danielle day-lewis is good i think
russell means is good i think
that the acting is terrific
i think the music is wonderful i think
it's gorgeously
shot and i can only find the director's
cut at this point the director's cut
absolutely kills the momentum of the
film by going on this long
rambling monologue thing
from chin gotchgook at the end of the
film when the much more succinct
version of that at the end of the
theatrical cut made the point a million
times better a million times stronger
and it just
lost me the longer it went on the
director's cut and i can't get that
original cut anymore i can't find it
everything the direct is the director's
cut so there i am back to the issue of
i've lost the experience i fell in love
with
and one could probably make an argument
that the director's cut
is a artistically superior version
i don't care it's not what i like
but i now can't have what i like
but for me there's another aspect
to the attempts of any artist
to update their work beyond
th their desire to refine
uh and maybe even correct what they see
as mistakes in the artistic expression
of what is out there whether it was
their own mistakes
or some outside force like a movie
studio
and there is also more issues than just
the audience
and the retention of their experience
and the ability to
experience that same thing again
the thing is the original piece of art
is a time capsule
it is a time capsule not only of
how the piece of art ended up the final
product
it is a time capsule of who the artist
all the artists and especially if we're
going to talk about something like film
it is a time
capsule of who they were
at the time it was made
so to go along with something that is
similar to the star wars thing to kind
of make my point
there was a special edition of steven
spielberg's et
that was done and released where
a couple of additional bits of footage
were added in
and somewhat more peculiarly
the cops who in the original were
holding guns
those guns were digitally removed or
replaced by walkie-talkies
because steven spielberg at the time
that
the special edition was released was not
comfortable with guns in the presence of
underage and child characters
whereas steven spielberg of 1982
[Music]
was and it's not
just changing the art it's breaking
the time capsule the retention
of who these people
were because you can take
any piece of art any movie any
book any painting any tv show
you take the same people
now and you put them together again
give them the exact same tools the same
if we're going to talk film let's say
the same budget the same script the same
cast all of it even setting aside like
oh the actors look older
forget that for a second if they made
the movie again
it would not be the same movie simply by
virtue of the fact that they are not the
same
people anymore they won't
make the exact same artistic decisions
that they did before
because they have changed as people
so for me what i find most frustrating
about
attempts by artists to
update their work
is that they are in a very real way kind
of erasing
history because this is a piece of
history
that retains not only the end result
but captures the people who made it
at the point that they participated in
its creation
at what point is a change
go from tinkering to altering
a piece of art it's kind of funny
because i think the answer is going to
differ
not only depending on who you ask but
even if you ask the same person about
two different
pieces of art they will give you a
different answer
there are people who will tell you
and swear by the purity
of the artist's intent and how that
should
always be respected
and that's usually you know when there
are calls from fans to say hey could you
take this out i found this offensive or
what have you
from those same kinds of sources i will
see those
those sorts of people argue on the one
hand
purity of artistic expression they
shouldn't have to change it
but on the other hand if the artist
actually wants
to change it if they like that piece of
art they will
kick up a huge storm it's incredibly
subjective
as much as it feels like it should have
an objective answer should artists be
allowed to alter their work
i don't know
it depends on the art it depends on the
work it depends on what the alteration
is
it depends on why they wish to alter it
it depends on whether or not it is going
to completely obliterate
the previous existing version or will
exist alongside it
and which one is more appropriate is
going to completely
differ in every dang
case
so if i have a point to this and i'm not
sure that i do but if i have a point
that point is probably don't
try and make absolute statements
about what artists should or shouldn't
be allowed to do
or what audiences should or shouldn't be
allowed to preserve
and save from their experience
because and this really is
the drum that i will keep beating on
nearly
every dang topic that i talk about
there is no absolute
nothing is ever always
it is going to vary it is going to
depend
so don't get up somebody's butt
because they said in one instance an
artist shouldn't be allowed to change
something and in another they say the
artist should change it
and also be aware
when you yourself are inconsistent
because we're all going to be
because the circumstances change the
answer
i really don't know why i felt the need
to talk about this
but it was kind of on my mind
and i wanted to talk my way through it
the and try and navigate the quagmire
just a little bit
if you've stuck through it this long
thank you for coming along with me
i have a patreon if you like what i do
and wish to support me and my ability to
keep doing it this is in fact my living
it's crazy any amount you're able to
give
does give you some kind of perk a reward
and obviously helps me out but even if
you can't
comment whatever your thoughts on what
i've talked about down in the
description
let's talk about it like share and
subscribe all that helps me out
but uh you also don't have to
it may not be your original artistic
intent to lend me that kind of
assistance
and if that's the case all i can say is
you are the council i'm just running the
meetings
and until next time this council is
[Music]
adjourned
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
um
[Music]
that was a rambling mess what am i doing